hey guys it's justine and today we are
gonna be doing a desk tour now this is
pretty much the ultimate desk tour i
have this set up to basically my
perfection now the one thing that you
will notice that is not perfect is my
cable management and this is like a real
desk tour like this is utility i didn't
set this up for you to be like wow
justine you're so neat and organized
because i'm absolutely i'm not this is
pretty much what i've been using since i
got the new mac studio which i
absolutely love and i also got a new
little edition from owc which is called
the mini stack now a lot of people have
used this previously with mac mini but
now this has become sort of the perfect
companion not only for the mac studio
but also my macbook pro a huge thank you
to owc for partnering with me on this
video they are pretty much my one stop
go-to solution for storage everything
that you're gonna see on this desk door
is pretty much powered by owc from the
thunderbolt dock that i have to this
really cool mini sack that i just got
and i can't wait to show you so let's
start the desk tour
[Music]
so here's the desk setup now what is so
exciting about this is the fact that i
do have three displays now two of these
are the pro display xdrs here on the
left and the right and in the center is
the new studio display and i
love having the studio display in the
center because i don't have to have an
additional microphone i don't have to
have an additional camera i've been
doing zoom calls off of here and it's so
great because this is such a huge wide
open space that i'm filming in right now
and having center stage be something
that is featured on the studio display
is so great because i can be doing my
calls i can still be walking around the
studio cleaning or setting it for the
next shoot while i'm still doing calls
and it still keeps me in frame i know
there's been a lot of drama over the
studio display and i don't i don't i
don't i don't i mean okay i get it but
also i don't really get it because i
have been editing absolutely everything
off of the studio display and it's
connected to the pro display xtr's right
next to it so what i've been doing is
using the center screen as kind of like
my timeline so that's where i'm doing
most of my editing so on the display
over here this is where i have the
output so i have the final product what
the video is going to look like so it's
just one full screen video while i'm
editing and then over here on the
vertical display which by the way
obsessed with vertical displays if
you've never tried it highly recommend
this is where i have my file browser so
i have all of my files everything that i
possibly could need to use in my project
and it's all right there and i can just
scroll i can add it to the timeline and
it is pretty much a dream come true for
editing so to make all of this work i'm
using this new mini stack stx now this
has been out for a little while but i
just got one and it has been so
incredible because it fits perfectly on
top of either a mac mini or my mac
studio now you can't actually see it
because it is behind my desk but this is
what it looks like what's really cool
about the mini stack stx is it is not
only giving you four thunderbolt ports
but it also has expandable storage up to
18 terabytes which is pretty freaking
incredible and i feel like this was
something that was so awesome with the
mac minis because you could easily stack
these up and it was kind of expanding
the mac mini to even more of its
potential but now adding this on with
the mac studio it's been honestly
incredible one of the things that i've
been using the mini stack stx for in
addition to the fact that i can use it
also as an external drive it has three
additional thunderbolt ports that i can
use for various accessories now what
i've been doing is switching this back
and forth between my macbook and my mac
studio so i unplugged this cable that's
going into the macbook right into the
mac studio and then i unplug the other
display and plug that into the mac
studio and just like that we've made a
quick transition from macbook to studio
with triple displays now this
thunderbolt dock is also one of my
favorites and this is something that i
travel with anytime i go anywhere and i
love this because not only does it give
me additional thunderbolt ports it also
gives me extra usb and even an sd card
slot but now the macbook does have an sd
card slot but you know if you need an
extra extra you've got it or if you have
a macbook that doesn't have an sd card
slot they've got you covered next up are
these thunderblade drives so i have an 8
terabyte and a 16 terabyte and these now
go all the way up to 32 terabytes which
is so impressive these are actually
solid state raid drives so i've been
using these to edit almost all of my
projects off of and they're absolutely
incredible they are a little bit
expensive so there are other options if
you are looking to cut costs but i'm
telling you if you're looking for
performance and storage look no further
they're incredible now we know that i
clearly shoot a lot of video content and
a lot of this video content needs
storage and i've already been talking a
lot about storage but this has been my
storage backup solution this is the
thunderbay flex 8. and with this there's
eight drive bays and you can get up to
144 terabytes of total storage so after
i'm done working on projects this is
where everything ends up so it's really
great to know that not only do i have
some of my most important projects
always stored on a separate drive but
this is also a backup to the backup so i
do usually have at least two or three
copies of a current project that i'm
working on but everything in the end
ends up on the thunder bay so this is
the home of pretty much everything i
know you guys may have seen that i
previously did a video with a jellyfish
server and the jellyfish server also is
housing a bunch of my other old archived
footage but i did in fact fill that
server up what was great about that
server is it was more of a server
situation so i could connect multiple
people to that at the same time and we
could all be working off of it but
pretty much now the workflow is all
remote so anytime i'm working with
someone we're either transferring
footage using frame io or dropbox or
whatever else people prefer or we're
just giving drives back and forth which
is actually
my next point
tiny little storage drives so these are
three of my favorite from owc so this
little owc electron this is actually two
terabytes this is cute cute but powerful
i've edited a ton of 4k footage directly
off of this drive and had zero issues
whatsoever jake can attest because this
is what i've been handing him back and
forth for footage
it's great so there are so many
different storage options that owc has
to offer and of course they range by
price by read write speed and of course
physical size as well so why i love
having sort of these smaller drives is
if we're shooting a video like this i
can save all of this stuff and i can
hand it to jake be like hey magic edit
time here you go so he takes that and
then he can go home and edit
it's pretty great okay i'm gonna take
that back now cause that's that one's
not yours so another thing that i have
connected here is my cf express a card
reader which also does read sd cards as
well because these are the cards that i
pretty much use i don't really use sd
cards anymore which is
a shame because there is a built-in port
on the macbook
i know i know and i like this desk a lot
because this
just pulls out just like so i've got my
little
keyboard
little mouse i have a nomad
mouse pad which is a nice leather which
is incredible love it then i my airpods
max which i use sometimes when i'm
editing but what's really great is the
fact that the studio display has
speakers built in if anybody wants to
come at me for loving the studio display
i'm here
something else that i've been doing is
drawing a lot got a little drawing
solution here so i can just do drawing
things
well thank you guys so much for watching
i really enjoyed making this video and
showing you guys a little look into how
i have my desk set up this has been so
much fun and it's also been super
productive and i'm such a huge fan of
this mini stack i didn't even know that
this was a thing and now that i know
i don't know how i've survived this long
without it it's probably one of my new
favorites so if you do have a mac studio
or even a mac mini this could definitely
be something that could help out your
workflow if you guys have any questions
feel free to leave them in the comments
below and i'll put links to all the
things that i talked about in this video
and let me know if there's anything that
you think that i might need to make this
even more effective i'll see you later
bye
[Music]